that is the best pizza I have ever tried
in my entire life
alright so we are in a Vegas baby and
city the Sin City that's why it looks
like we're in a very strange makeshift
set yeah this is our lighting right now
basically what we're gonna be doing is
Chris and Spencer went out and bought us
the worst reviewed pizza in Vegas and
the best reviewed pizza we're gonna be
trying it and or stew I mean in theory
though pieces shouldn't be that hard to
mess up I've had terrible pizza in my
life I also had great pizza in my life
so I don't know like actually is not
good
Glee see I don't like really I put the
napkins sometimes when it is that bad
you know what pisses me off though
though those people that take a knife
and fork and thing by folding I fold I'm
ready for meat I'm gonna hold it cuz we
only have two people right now in this
real yeah I got it which one do you want
to try first
rock paper scissor Rock Paper Scissors
shoot Oh this actually caught my eye
more interesting and I would rather try
this all right you try it you go first
thing you want me to go first you go for
it okay I'll try this go on little buddy
with that sound Wow is it good dude I'm
not hungry I'm not even a little bit
hungry
I was almost nauseous too helpful I
wasn't healthy I did not want to eat
this I want to eat this whole damn thing
it is so good the sauce is incredible I
think what makes a pizza is the sauce
and this sauce like has this almost like
just insane freshness and it tastes like
honestly the best sauce I've ever I've
ever taste it tastes like tomatoes from
like a fresh Italian garden and the
crust it's like very soft which I know
some people don't like but it's like
dough yer it tastes like a like a really
light food like I don't feel sick I
don't feel greasy or nauseous or
anything from it so I really like this
it's like a tomato soup
with bread is that a terrible way to
describe pizza it's the kind of people I
like so okay moving on to mine it's like
a little burnt on the outside which I
like and there's a bunch of little
bubbles get your little little
boundaries thing right here this isn't
what I would imagine the worst reviewed
pizza to look like you know what I mean
yeah I mean this might be the best I
don't know the best beat soundtrack ever
but that's the best piece you've ever
had new life might be honestly yeah yeah
you're so confident in saying this is
the best pizza you've ever had in your
life yeah it's the best beats ever track
wondering % not even sarcastic at all
you can't say with a straight face I
don't trust you that is the best pizza I
have ever tried in my entire life hmm
it's crunchy does sound punchy
I think I agree with the people of Las
Vegas oh wow
there is tomato sauce in pizza and I do
not taste a single drop oh he's made a
sauce in this this is just cheese and
crust damn like do you see any red or
like any orange colored cheese yes
cheese and crust this is a grilled
cheese if you put this on this tomato
soup right here that might be a good
company there's no tomatoes left yeah I
don't see anything in there I love the
crust so I'm gonna pull yeah crust I'm
just gonna dab a little just I'll just
have a little bite of this right here I
do like the crust but yeah this this
tomato sauce situation needs to be
worked out there's no sauce not try it
because you gotta try it yeah let's do
it don't eat too much of it cuz I want
to finish it all right see Geoff Johns
and germ-free all right let me try this
[Music]
yeah that's pretty good interesting
there's pretty look isn't the best pizza
you've ever had
well they got it no it's not the best
news I ever had but they got one thing
right that this pizza didn't tomato
sauce it's all about the sauce well no
more
no okay Chris can you actually try cuz
you're the piece Abscam get one quick
dip efforts hmm I feel like it's lemony
that's what yeah that's so good take
reviews with a grain of salt man this
was a fun experience and it was
definitely not the worst pizza ever had
it was the best pizza ever had for me
personally don't always rely on the
reviews that you find online maybe just
ask some people that live nearby maybe
they can give you an honest opinion of
where you should go or trust the reviews
and find the best pizza in the world
like I did
[Music]